It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Do you worry that your boss is gaslighting you? Do you think your ex is a narcissist? Are you considering setting some boundaries around your relationship with a difficult friend? In recent years, these terms gaslighting, narcissism, boundaries, and others have become part of the vocabularies of millions of Americans. Therapy speak, it seems, is everywhere, changing the way many of us think about and talk about our friends, our family, our relationships, and ourselves. So what's behind this rise in therapy speak? What do psychologists and other mental health professionals think about it? What are some of the
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会受到数据流量降速的影响。你是否担心老板在对你进行煤气灯操纵（精神控制）？你是否认为你的前任是个自恋者？你是否正在考虑与一位难相处的朋友设定一些界限？近年来，煤气灯操纵、自恋、界限等词汇已成为数百万美国人词汇表的一部分。治疗术语似乎无处不在，改变了我们许多人思考和谈论朋友、家人、人际关系以及我们自身的方式。那么，治疗术语兴起的背后是什么？心理学家和其他心理健康专业人士对此有何看法？有哪些
most common words popping up in movies, TV shows, news articles, social media, and elsewhere? And are these terms being used correctly or are misunderstandings cropping up when they make the leap from therapy to popular culture? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Taisha Caldwell Harvey.
最常见的词汇出现在电影、电视节目、新闻文章、社交媒体和其他地方？这些术语使用得正确吗？还是当它们从治疗领域进入流行文化时产生了误解？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是 Kim Mills。今天我们有两位嘉宾。首先是 Taisha Caldwell Harvey 博士。
Dr. Caldwell Harvey is the founder and CEO of the Black Girl Doctor, a virtual therapy practice that specializes in mental health and wellness for black women. Before starting the Black Girl Doctor in 2017, Dr. Caldwell Harvey earned a PhD in counseling psychology, completed a a postdoctoral fellowship at the University of California Irvine and spent seven years as a mental health consultant for the University of California system. She has published academic articles on wellness, career selection, and achievement motivation. Also with us is Dr. Aaron Parks, a clinical psychologist, researcher, and entrepreneur who specializes in evidence-based treatment for eating disorders. She's the co-founder and chief clinical officer of Equip, an online treatment program for eating disorders. Before founding a quip, she was the director of outreach and admissions at the UC San Diego
Caldwell Harvey 博士是 Black Girl Doctor 的创始人和首席执行官，这是一家专门为黑人女性提供心理健康和保健服务的虚拟治疗诊所。在 2017 年创办 Black Girl Doctor 之前，Caldwell Harvey 博士获得了咨询心理学博士学位，在加州大学欧文分校完成了博士后研究，并曾在加州大学系统担任了七年的心理健康顾问。她发表过关于健康、职业选择和成就动机的学术文章。与我们在一起的还有临床心理学家、研究员和企业家 Aaron Parks 博士，她专门从事饮食失调的循证治疗。她是 Equip 的联合创始人和首席临床官，Equip 是一家针对饮食失调的在线治疗项目。在创办 Equip 之前，她曾担任加州大学圣地亚哥分校
Eating Disorders Center. Dr. Parks and Dr. Caldwell Harvey discussed the rise of Therapy Speak in an article in a recent issue of APA's magazine, Monitor on Psychology. Welcome to you both. Thank you for joining me. Thanks so much for having me. We're excited to be here. Why do you think we're seeing this increase in therapy speak right now? Is this something new, or of these concepts from psychology made their way into pop culture before? I don't know if it's entirely new. I'm not sure if people remember in the 90s when all of a sudden everybody was codependent, a word that from the 70s, 80s, enough until like 1990, was a word that you
饮食失调中心的推广和招生主任。Parks 博士和 Caldwell Harvey 博士在 APA 杂志《心理学监测》最近的一期文章中讨论了治疗术语的兴起。欢迎两位。感谢你们加入我的节目。非常感谢邀请我。我们很高兴来到这里。你们认为为什么我们现在看到了治疗术语的增加？这是什么新鲜事吗，还是这些心理学概念以前就进入过流行文化？我不确定这是否完全是新的。我不确定人们是否还记得 90 年代，当时突然每个人都成了“共依存者”，这个词从 70 年代、80 年代一直到 1990 年左右，还是一个你
only heard in psychology textbooks or in a therapist office, but then suddenly all of us were. But that being said, I was trying to think of other words from the 90s, and that's like the only one I could think of. And now I feel like I could think of dozens of therapy speak. Yeah, that's so interesting. I wonder, I feel like it has a lot to do with just how social media can spread information so fast. Right. So before, as it would have taken maybe a year for something to catch on at the level that it can catch on overnight now,
只在心理学教科书或治疗师办公室里听到的词，但突然间我们所有人都成了这样。但话虽如此，我当时在想 90 年代的其他词，那是我唯一能想到的。而现在我觉得我能想到几十个治疗术语。是的，这太有趣了。我想，我觉得这与社交媒体传播信息的速度有很大关系。对吧。所以以前，某种东西要达到现在一夜之间就能达到的流行程度，可能需要一年时间，
is why we're noticing that so many people are using these terms. As psychologists, do you think this is a good thing? Mightn't it indicate that the public is becoming more familiar? with and maybe more comfortable with the concept of mental illness or mental disorders. Yeah, I really think that there is some good to it. And I feel like as people, we really don't like to sit in duality very much. But that is really what this is. I think there is some good and there is some bad and probably some very good and some very bad. And we're just sitting at the intersection of all of that. But in terms of the representation or the good part, I feel like people are
这就是为什么我们注意到这么多人正在使用这些术语。作为心理学家，你们认为这是一件好事吗？这难道不表明公众对心理疾病或心理障碍的概念变得更加熟悉，甚至可能更加自在了吗？是的，我真的认为这其中有一些好处。我觉得作为人类，我们真的不太喜欢处于二元对立中。但这确实就是现状。我认为有好的一面，也有坏的一面，可能还有非常好的一面和非常坏的一面。我们正处于所有这些的交汇点。但就代表性或好的一面而言，我觉得人们
wanting language to talk about what's going on with them internally instead of avoiding it. And so I love that about what's happening. Dr. Parks, you agree? I agree that there is good, there's bad. And I think any of us who've been to a party recently might say there's also the insufferable, the person who won't stop using their every time. It covers the whole spectrum. I am glad that people have the term abuse, which was a term that was more often said in a
渴望用语言来谈论他们内心发生的事情，而不是回避它。所以我喜欢正在发生的这一切。Parks 博士，你同意吗？我同意有好有坏。我想我们中任何最近参加过聚会的人可能都会说，还有那些令人难以忍受的人，那些每次开口都停不下来的人。它涵盖了整个范围。我很高兴人们有了“虐待”这个词，这是一个在临床上更常被提及的词，现在人们可以识别它是什么了。而且，将你经历的每一次负面互动都贴上自恋、有毒或创伤的标签，可能会造成一些伤害。因此，弄清楚我们什么时候是在为了好事使用它？什么时候是在为了令人讨厌而使用它？什么时候它实际上在伤害我们和我们所爱的人？那么我刚才提到的那个观点，即使用这种语言是否正在减少围绕心理疾病的污名化？你看到它在那样起作用吗？我认为可以。这让我想起 WebMD 刚出来的时候。起初，人们真的很担心，比如，哦，每个人都会认为自己是医生，他们可以自我诊断。但它真正做到的是使我们所有人都能成为更好的医疗保健消费者，并对自己健康有更多了解。我认为治疗术语可能也是如此，你不必非得在办公室进行一对一的治疗才能开始了解自己身上发生了什么。这本身就开始去污名化了。当它对普通人来说是可及的，而不仅仅是专业人士对你说的话时。Caldwell Harvey 博士，你认为它是在减少污名化，还是因为每个人都在
clinical way and now people can recognize what it is. And there's probably some harm being done by labeling every negative interaction you have as narcissistic or toxic or trauma. And so figuring out, when are we using it for good? When are we using it to be insufferable? And when is it actually harming us and our loved ones? What about the idea I alluded to a minute ago that maybe using this language is reducing stigma around mental illness? Do you see it working that way? I think it can be. And it reminds me when WebMD first came out. And at first, people were really concerned, like, oh, everyone's going to think that they're a doctor and they can diagnose themselves. But what it really did is enabled us all to be better consumers of health care and also more knowledgeable about our own health. And I think the same thing might be true with therapy speak, that you don't have to be in an office having one-to-one therapy to start learning a little bit about what's going on with you. And that in and of itself starts to destigmatize it. when it's accessible to the lay person and not just something a professional says to you. Dr. Caldwell, Harvey, do you think it's reducing stigma or maybe making it worse because everybody's
乱用这些词而使情况变得更糟？是的，我认为它有潜力同时做到这两点，而且我见过它同时发生，对吧？所以我认为当你遇到一个你以前没听过的词，并且它定义了你的经历时，这非常有力量。这真的可以去污名化，对吧？因为现在你可以去寻求护理。你可以知道该去谷歌搜索什么，以及进一步研究你身上发生的事情。但与此同时，当词汇被以不一定准确的方式使用时，也存在这种危险。所以，你知道，有很多人在谈论“抑郁”。如果他们描述它的方式与临床抑郁症的样子并不相符，那么真正患有
throwing the words around? Yeah, I think it has the potential to do a little bit of both, and I've seen it do both, right? So I think there's something really powerful when you come across a word that you haven't heard before, and it defines your experience. And that can be really destigmatizing, right? Because now you can go in, and seek care. You can know what to Google and to research further about, you know, something that's going on for you. But at the same time, there is this danger also around using words when are used in ways that aren't necessarily accurate in particular. And so, you know, you have lots of people talking about, you know, being depressed. And if they're describing it in a way that it's not actually what a clinical depression looks like, the person that's genuinely suffering with
临床抑郁症的人在看着，公众也在看着。而这现在成了他们对抑郁症的认知。因此，我非常痛苦的经历可以很容易地被最小化。公众对我所经历的事情的看法可能会被最小化。现在我是否在经历羞耻感，对吧？因为，你知道，如果这个人可以在网上看起来那么棒，并以如此轻松的方式谈论他们的抑郁症，而我有抑郁症，我正在挣扎，我无法起床，我正面临一些重大的挑战。
the clinical depression is watching that and the public is watching that. And this is now their representation of what depression is. And so my very painful experience could be minimized really easily. And public perception of what I'm experiencing can be minimized. And now is there a shame that I'm experiencing, right? Because, you know, if this person can, you know, look so amazing online and talk about their depression in such a light way and I have depression and I'm struggling and I can't get out of bud and I'm having some significant challenges.
世界上对我来说同情心就少了。我理解自己挑战的能力也变弱了，无法以一种有帮助的方式去理解。所以，我再次强调，我总是想到二元对立的交汇点，净效应是更多的好处吗？还是更多的坏处？对于这一点，我很担心。我甚至看到它作为提供者出现在我身上，曾经有一段时间，当有人说，
There's less compassion for me in the world. There's less ability for me to understand my own, you know, challenges in a way that is helpful. And so, again, I always think about, again, at the intersection of the duality, is the net more good? Is it more bad? And this one, I'm concerned. I even see it come up for me as a provider that there was a time when someone said,
我经历了创伤，或者我爸爸是个自恋者，我可能更有可能照单全收。而现在，当有人说，哦，我有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）时，我想，哦，我能感觉到内心那个批评者和怀疑论者在说，我觉得我真的需要核实和验证。我想当我处于最糟糕的状态时，那个内心批评者的解读是不友善的，如果这说得通的话，对吧？就像我处于最糟糕的状态时，我几乎是从怀疑的角度出发，而不是从好奇的角度出发。是的，你知道，我们有一位嘉宾，我想是去年某个时候，
I experienced trauma or my dad's a narcissist, and I probably was more likely to take it at face value. And now today, when someone says, oh, I have PTSD, I think, oh, do I can feel the inner critic and skeptic in me that feels like I really need to verify and validate. And I think when I'm at my worst, that inner critic is unkind in its interpretation, if that makes sense, right? Like I almost start from a place of doubt instead of starting from a place with curiosity when I'm showing up at my worst. Yeah, you know, we had a guest, I think it was sometime last year,
她正在接受强迫症治疗，她想让听众知道，当人们说“哦，我有点强迫症”时，她感到很痛苦。我的意思是，她真的觉得这轻视了她所经历的一切。所以，我的意思是，我真的认为这反映了你们俩刚才所说的。我们在饮食失调中也经常看到这种情况。它往往是一种人们真的认为是虚荣心障碍或选择性障碍的疾病，而不是我们认为其他心理健康障碍是遗传的或环境与其他风险因素结合的结果。我认为这与人们接触饮食文化和饮食失调有很大关系。他们会说，哦，我也曾长时间节食。我也曾尝试过这些不健康的事情，因此我知道什么是饮食失调。有些人很快就会说我患有饮食失调，而他们真正患的可能只是饮食紊乱。就像“我有强迫症”一样，而他们真正拥有的可能只是一个有一些特殊性格的人格。所以我认为随之而来的伤害在于，它对其他人来说贬低了它，意思是，好吧，我克服了我的饮食失调。那么你为什么还在为你的挣扎，而你真正患的只是饮食紊乱或不健康的
who was being treated for obsessive-compulsive disorder, and she wanted listeners to know that it's painful to her when people say things like, oh, I'm a little OCD. I mean, she really felt that this trivialized what she was going through. So, I mean, I really think that that mirrors what you've both just said. We see it in eating disorders a lot, too. it tends to be a disorder that people really think is a disorder of vanity or a disorder of choice instead of the way we think of other mental health disorders being either genetic or a combination
与食物的关系，或者生活在我们的饮食文化社会中？我经常听到的一个词是人们谈论“共依存”。Caldwell Harvey 博士，你认为这是人们真正理解的东西，还是他们只是随口一说，误解了关系中真正发生的事情？是的。我想可能两者都有。我总是，我感到犹豫，不想批评某人在流行文化中表现出来的那种被认为是真实的东西。这只是我一直在思考这个话题的事情之一。你知道，认识论，也就是研究人们如何获得知识的学科。我认为这正在改变，我们真的必须理解某人认为什么是真实的，为什么，以及他们认为什么是可信的来源。我认为有时医疗专业人士对于特定群体或特定主题来说，并不是关于某事是什么的可信来源。
of our environment and other risk factors. And I think that has a lot to do with people's accessibility to diet culture and disordered eating. They're like, oh, I also restrict for a large period of time. I also have tried these unhealthy things before and thus I know what an eating disorder is. some people are quick to say I had an eating disorder when maybe what they really had was disordered eating. Same thing with I have OCD when what they really have is a personality that might have some particularities. And so I think the harm that can go with it is then it diminishes it for other people in the sense of like, well, I got over my eating disorder. So why are you still struggling with yours when what you really had was disordered eating or an unhealthy
所以我一直在努力寻找平衡，仅仅是理解某人通过这个词想要表达什么。所以，如果文化已经抓住了“共依存”这个概念，我确实认为临床医生显然应该发布教育资源，解释临床术语。但我们也有义务深入了解文化如何定义共依存，然后利用这一点来支持人们。我觉得当我们试图辩论和对抗时，我不确定这是否能带我们达到我们想要的最终结果。你知道，现在外面有很多另一个词是“自恋”。我只是想知道，你们中有人认为人们完全理解那是什么吗？我的意思是，这是一种可诊断的心理疾病。确实是。而且它的基准率非常、非常、非常、非常低。我记得试图教授心理学 101，并试图找到像自恋的视频例子。并没有很多。而你可以展示这里有一个评估中患有焦虑症的人的视频，或者一个评估中患有抑郁症的人的视频。
relationship with food or living in our diet culture society? One of the terms I hear a lot is people talking about codependency. Dr. Caldwell-Harvard, do you think that that's something that people really understand, or they're just throwing it out there and mistaking what's really going on in the relationship? Yeah. I think there's probably a little bit of both. And I always, I feel hesitant to criticize what somebody has come to know to be true in the way that it shows up in popular culture. And it's just one of the things that I've been thinking about a lot about this topic. You know, the epistemomomal, you know, the epistemology. which is the study of how people come to know. And I think that is changing and that we really have to understand what is it that somebody believes to be true and why and what are they believe as trusted sources. And I think sometimes medical professionals are not the people for particular communities or particular topics that are the trusted source for that group on what something is.
但如果你浏览社交媒体，根据它被使用的频率，你可能会认为十分之一的人是临床自恋者。我认为这有点像 Caldwell Harvey 博士所说的，他们使用它得到了什么？他们是否需要，拥有一个说“这是一个本质上行为对我有害的人”的术语是否赋予了他们力量？所以我不再与他们建立关系了。我觉得它在前任身上用得很多，这是我经常看到的地方。
And so I'm constantly trying to find a balance between just understanding what somebody is meaning by this. So if, you know, the culture has grasped on to this idea of what codependency is, I do think that obviously, you know, clinicians should be putting out educational resources and that explain, you know, clinical terms. But we also have this obligation to lean in and just understand what the culture defines as codependency and then use that to support people. And I feel like when we try to debate and combat, I don't know that it's going to get us to the end result that we're looking for. You know, another term that's out there a lot these days is narcissism. And I'm just wondering, do either of you believe that people fully understand what that is? I mean, it is a diagnosable mental illness. It is. And it has a very, very, very, very low base rate. I remember trying to teach, you know, psychology 101 and trying to find like video examples of narcissism. And there's not a ton of them. Whereas you could show here's a video of someone in an assessment who had anxiety or a video of someone in an assessment with depression.
什么时候它在关系中造成了永久性的损害？是的。Parks 博士，我非常同意你的观点。我认为在人们的关系层面，当你给某人贴上像自恋这样强烈的标签时，你就不太可能想要修复那种关系了。而且它也太绝对了。我认为你称某人，在任何类型的关系中，为自恋者。
But if you looked through social media, you would think that maybe one in ten people were clinical narcissists based on how often it's being used. And I think it goes a little bit to what Dr. Cable Harvey is saying is, what are they getting out of using it? Do they need, is it empowering them to have a term that says, this is a person who inherently how they behave is harmful to me? and so I am no longer in a relationship with them. Tends to be used a lot with exes, I feel like, is where I see it a lot.
在某些方面，他们使用得很准确。他们是在说，嘿，这是你本质的一部分，你无法关闭它，或者很难关闭它。如果你希望将关系推进到那一点之外，对某人说这样的话是多么具有破坏性。但我会假设很少有人真正知道自恋者的临床定义是什么。类似于我认为“边缘型”也被非常不准确地乱用。不久前我们做了一整集关于边缘型人格障碍的节目。它现在是我们目录中 230 多集里收听率最高的一集。我认为人们确实想理解这些术语的含义。
And when is it creating permanent damage in a relationship? Yeah. Dr. Parks, I really agree with you. And I think in the relational aspect of people, when you label somebody with something that is so strong as something like narcissism, you then have a less likelihood of wanting to repair that relationship. And it's so final, too. I think that you call someone near in a relationship with whatever type of relationship, a narcissist.
而且我认为我们花了很多时间做这些播客来帮助人们更好地理解。因为我认为人们可能只是在乱用这些词，就像我们刚才谈到的那样，而某人可能只是自我中心。有很强的自我意识。这使他们成为自恋者吗？那么，你们认为通过互相抛出这些心理诊断，这对人们的关系以及我们互相互动的方式有什么影响？我认为当你使用它们来了解自己并向内看时，我很高兴人们拥有丰富的方式来更多地了解自己和人性。我认为一旦你开始向外使用这些术语给其他人贴标签
In some ways, they're using it accurately. They're saying, like, hey, this is a core part of who you are and you can't turn it off or it's hard to turn it off. And what a damaging thing to say to someone if you ever wish to move the relationship beyond that point. But I would assume that very, very few people actually know what the clinical definition of a narcissist is. similar to how I think borderline gets thrown around a lot as well in a very inaccurate way. We did a whole episode not long ago on borderline personality disorder. It is now the most listened to episode of the more than 230 episodes we have in our catalog. And I think people that do want to understand what these terms mean.
或给其他情况贴标签时，我认为，通常情况下，这可能是有害的，不仅是对另一个人。所以那个人可能永远不知道你在称他们为自恋者。但在哪些方面它损害了你从与那个人的任何互动中学习的能力？通过说，嘿，我的前任是个自恋者，几乎是在说我把 100% 的责任都推给了他们，因为他们身上有一些根本性的东西，导致他们无法以不同的方式对待我。相反，如果你说，好吧，那个人处于他们生活中需要把工作当作全部生活的阶段。所以他们没有处于能够建立关系的位置。这允许更多的细微差别和更深入的理解，你可以从那段关系中真正学到什么。
And I think we spend a lot of time doing these podcasts to help people better understand. Because I think people may be just throwing these words around, like as we just talked about, And somebody may be just self-involved. Have a very strong ego. Does that make them a narcissist? So what is this doing, do you think, to people's relationships in the way that we interact with each other by just throwing out these psychological diagnoses at each other? I think when you're using them to get to know yourself and look inward, I'm glad people have a rich array of ways in which to learn more about themselves and their humanity. I think as soon as you're starting to use these terms outward to put labels on other people
所以我认为它肯定伤害了被贴标签的人，其中许多人永远不会知道，但它也会伤害你，因为你没有从更深层次去审视你能从这种情况中学到什么。是的，我同意。而且我想补充一点，我认为很多，我的意思是，我假设大多数人并不是想通过使用这种语言来造成伤害。他们是在试图做一些有帮助的事情来解释他们的经历。我认为这是我看到的负面一面的第二类，即假设你的个人经历与关于这个理论或概念的更大讨论如此相关，以至于值得辩论。我在另一篇文章中谈到“冒名顶替综合症”就是一个很好的例子。我最近看到很多人分享说，我没有那个。我一生中从未经历过那个。我一直都很自信。我明白了。当有人听到什么是冒名顶替现象时，有些人会被冒犯。他们会说，你不理解，但背景因素，所有这些事情。我明白了。但我也在想，那很好，
or labels on other situations is when you are, I think, more often than not, it could be harmful, not just to the other person. So that other person might never know that you're calling them a narcissist. But in what ways is it harming your ability to learn from whatever your interactions were with that person? By saying, hey, my ex was a narcissist almost says I'm putting 100% of blame onto them because they have something fundamental about them that they couldn't act in a different way with me. Instead, if you're like, well, that person was in a part of their life where they needed to make their job their whole life. And so they weren't in a place to have a relationship. It allows for more nuance and a more deeper understanding of what you could actually take away from that relationship.
那是你的经历。但因为它是你的经历，它意味着什么？它是每个人的经历吗？那有什么作用？当它是像理论这样的东西时，感觉它没有那么有害，但它实际上可能非常有害。我希望没有人会走来走去说，我从未患过抑郁症。我一直只是一个非常积极的人，对吧？你可以非常清楚地看到这对那些确实经历过
So I think it harms certainly the person who gets labeled, many of whom will never know, but it can also harm you because you don't look at a deeper level of what you could have learned from a situation. Yeah, I agree. And I would add that I think a lot of, I mean, I assume that most people aren't trying to cause harm by using this language. They're trying to do something helpful to explain their experience. And I think that's the second category that I see as the negative side of this, which is assuming that your personal experience is so relevant to the greater discussion on this theory or this concept that it's worthy of like, debate. And I talked in the other article just around imposter syndrome is a really good example. I more recently seen a lot of people sharing like, I don't have that. I have never experienced that in my life. And I've always been really confident. And I get it. When someone hears what imposter's phenomenon is, some people get offended by it. And I're like, you're not understanding, but contextual factors, all these things. I get it. And I'm also thinking, that's very nice that
抑郁症或与抑郁症共存的人来说是多么具有破坏性。所以这些其他术语，我认为人们认为他们只是在进行有益的辩论，但它可能真的、真的非常有害。我们永远不会让没有经历过的人成为关于如此严肃的事情（即你的心理健康）的讨论的中心。我认为那部分很重要。如果它不适用于你，你是怎么成为中心的？当你谈论事情时，真的要考虑这一点。我真的很喜欢你谈论它如何让人们有词来描述某事。然而有时这个词变得如此简化。
that has been your experience. But because it's your experience, does it mean? that it is everybody's experience. And what does that do? When it's something like a theory, it feels like it's not as harmful, but it actually can be really harmful. Nobody would walk around, I hope, and say, I've never had depression. I've always just been a very positive person, right? And you could really clearly see how damaging that could be to somebody who does experience
我想到边缘型人格障碍，即使在临床医生中，在饮食失调领域，饮食失调和边缘型人格障碍在患有饮食失调的成年人之间有很多共病。我开始问临床医生，当我在图表中看到这个病人是边缘型时，告诉我更多你的意思。他们会说，哦，他们自残。其他人会说，哦，他们有非常严重的情绪调节问题。其他人会说他们根本不知道自己是谁。或者其他人会说，哦，他们太烦人了，他们和每个人都打架。他们爱你，他们恨你。
depression or our lips with depression. And so these other terms, I think people think they're just engaging in helpful debate, but it can be really, really harmful. And we would never center the person who hasn't had the experience in a discussion about something that is so serious and it's your mental health. And I think that that part is important. If it doesn't apply to you, how did you become the center and to really think about that when you're talking about things? I really like how you're talking about how it gives people something to have a word for something. And yet sometimes this word becomes so reductive.
就像你会听到五种不同的东西。每个人都会以不同的方式描述它。我想，哇。所以通过使用这个词，我们实际上比我们想象的更不善于沟通。我们如何才能说这个人调节情绪有困难，而不是这个人有边缘型人格障碍，或者如果它被以更外行的方式使用，那么“太边缘型”？你的夏天从家得宝的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四头燃气烤架来点燃夏季烧烤了，特价
And I think about that with borderline, even within clinicians, in the eating disorder space, there's a lot of comorbidity between eating disorders and borderline personality disorder and adults with eating disorders. And I started asking clinicians when I would see in the chart this patient as borderline, tell me more about what you mean. And they'd say, oh, they self-harm. And other people would say, oh, they have really bad emotional regulation. And other people would say they have no idea who they are. Or other people would say, oh, they're so annoying and they get into fights with everybody. They love you and they hate you.
仅需 199 美元，并用仅需 49 美元的 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装整季招待客人。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝获得低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请见 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步。我们省了多少钱？
Like you'd hear like five different things. Everyone would describe it differently. And I'm like, wow. So by using this one term, we actually are being less communicative than we think we are. And how can we instead say this person's having difficulty regulating their emotions instead of this person has borderline or is so borderline if it's being used in a more layman's way? Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special
足够了。足够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。离水边只有几步之遥。希尔顿促销现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可节省 20%，获得你期待的住宿。
buy for only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, US-only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save?
当你想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时。你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了住宿。你认为它正在以一种有害的方式渗入治疗吗？我的意思是，治疗师是否完全理解他们正在使用的术语？他们是否在进行他们应该进行的测试，以了解某人是否真的患有像边缘型人格障碍这样很难诊断的疾病？我不知道这是否有争议，但我不认为每个人都知道他们在会谈中使用的术语。我认为关于人类经验有太多东西需要了解。
Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected.
有太多的术语。没有人能读完研究生课程就知道每一种治疗方式并深入了解一切。我想这就是为什么，你知道，我们称我们所做的事情为“实践”。但我们如何确保我们有时间在日常生活中真正去实践？因为我确实认为，特别是对于我们所有花相当多时间上网的人来说，这些词确实渗入了我们的词汇，无论是社交还是专业。然后我们有时会误用它们吗？这会伤害客户吗？这种文化转变如何影响了你的临床工作？Caldwell Harvey 博士，你为什么不回答那个问题？这是一个有趣的问题。我确实看到我的客户更多地使用这种语言。我喜欢跟上技术，了解社交媒体上发生的事情。所以我尽我所能保持一只脚在里面，一只脚在外面。但我确实注意到如果我离线太久，人们开始说一些事情。
When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Do you think that it's creeping into treatment in a way that's kind of harmful, though? I mean, like, are therapists fully understanding the terms that they're using? Are they giving the tests that they should give in order to understand whether somebody actually has something like borderline, which is very hard to diagnose? I don't know if this is controversial, but I don't think everybody knows the terms that they're using in session. I think that there's so much to know about the human experience.
我心想，他们在说什么？但我还注意到我读了很多书和正在流行、我的客户关注和收听的书的回忆录。我读的很多回忆录，我非常惊讶他们的治疗师被引用了多少，或者实际上没有被引用，但他们在治疗中学到的信息在这些书中被作为来自公众人物的建议复述出来。我有时在想，噢，你的治疗师可能需要一个署名。所以在这方面，有时我读到一些东西，我想，哇，那是一个非常了不起的、关于某人经历过的事情以及如何使用心理学和概念以及你可以在治疗中学到的东西来度过难关的个人描述。他们只是画出了非常有力的例子。而其他时候，我感到震惊。那是应用这个概念的糟糕例子。
there are so many terms. Nobody finishes grad school knowing every single modality of treatment and getting to go in depth and everything. And I guess that's why, you know, we call what we do practicing. But how do we make sure that there is time in our days to actually practice? Because I do think, especially for all of us who spend a decent amount of time online, these words do creep into our vocabulary, both socially and professionally. And then are we sometimes misusing them? And does that harm the client? How has this culture shift affected your clinical work? Dr. Caldwell Harvey, why don't you take that one? It's an interesting question. I see my clients using the language more for sure. I like to stay up with technology, what's happening on social media. So I do my best to keep one foot in, one foot out. But I do notice if I'm offline too long, people start saying things.
然后我听着我的客户进来，他们关注网上的这些人。他们遵循他们的建议。所以就我的工作而言，它确实是围绕着，部分是做好的临床工作，但要更加协调，必须深入了解人们在说什么，并且真的不要对他们认为什么是真实的做出假设。所以客户可以说，我真的开始关注自我护理了。我以前可能会对那意味着什么做出一些假设，但我真的不能做出任何假设。我真的必须说，告诉我你到底在做什么。
I'm like, what are they talking about? But what I also notice is that I read a lot of books and memoirs of books that are trending that my clients follow and listen to. And a lot of memoirs I read, I'm so surprised at how much their therapist is quoted or not actually quoted, but the information that they're learning in therapy is regurgitated in these books as advice coming from public figures. and I'm sometimes thinking, ooh, your therapist probably needs a byline. And so in that, sometimes I read things and I'm like, wow, that is a really remarkable, like, personal description of, you know, something someone has gone through and how to use psychology and concepts and what you can learn in therapy to move through something. And they just paint really powerful examples. And other times, I am horrified. That is a horrible example of how to apply this concept.
我有客户说他们把洗衣服作为他们的自我护理。我说，那，那不会是。那不会奏效。再说一次，我是在说一些稍微琐碎的事情，但我认为在它的更深层根源上，人们可以真正开始做一些事情，比如从事我所说的生产性行为，或者照顾你的日常琐事，并认为他们已经做了他们能做的一切来照顾自己。如果我不小心，不去真正分解休息到底意味着什么。这简直是，可能对于几乎
And then I'm listening to my clients coming in and they follow these people online. They're following their advice. And so in terms of my work, it's really around, and part of it is doing good clinical work, but being more attuned to having to lean in to what people are saying and really not make assumptions about what they believe to be true. And so a client can say, I'm really getting into self-care. And I might make some assumptions before about what that means, but I really can't make any assumptions. And I really have to say, tell me exactly what you're doing.
我所有的客户，我们都进行过关于定义休息意味着什么的对话。它并不意味着他们基于他们在文化中的经历所认为的意思。我只是认为这只是它影响临床实践的一个例子，但它也给了你谈论的东西。所以如果有一个趋势，我们可以在会谈中谈论它，并讨论它如何影响他们以及他们是如何解读的。那么当他们开始使用这些术语时，你会发现自己经常纠正客户吗？
And I've had clients, you know, saying they're doing laundry as their self-care. And I'm like, that is, that's not going to be it. That's not going to work. And again, I'm, you know, saying something a little bit more trivial, but I think at a deeper root of it is people can genuinely start doing things like engaging in what I would call like productive behaviors or getting, you know, taking care of your daily routine and thinking that they've done all they can do to care for themselves. And if I'm not careful and really breaking down what does it actually mean to rest? It's literally one of the, probably for almost
我不会。我不会。我真的觉得如果它是那种我认为可能会造成伤害的完全偏离轨道的东西，我会，但我真的只是深入倾听。我觉得纠正人们会给关系制造障碍。所以，再次强调，我作为治疗师的角色是倾听你的理解是什么，并帮助你以那种方式驾驭生活。所以，再次强调，如果有一个大的领域需要重定向，我们最终会到达那里。但除此之外，我只是在学习你认为什么是真实的。
all of my clients, we've had conversations about defining what it means to rest. And it not meaning what they believe it to mean based on their experience. in culture. And I just think that's just one example of the way it impacts clinical practice, but it also gives you stuff to talk about. So if there's a trend, we can talk about it in session and talk through how it impacts them and how they're interpreting. Do you find yourself correcting clients then a fair amount when they start using these terms?
我认为对我们来说，它在饮食失调治疗中经常与创伤一起出现。每个人一生中都会经历创伤，并不是每个人都会发展成 PTSD。虽然我真的很高兴“创伤”这个词现在进入了公众词汇，因为人们经历了非常创伤的事情却忘记将其标记为这样。就像，你度过了那个难关，你幸存下来，你坚持下来，这是一件大事。当有人进入治疗并说他们有 PTSD 时，确保我们所有的临床医生和我知道，给他们 PTSD 清单，不是为了我们可以说你经历或没经历过创伤，而是因为你处理它的方式会非常不同。如果他们经历过创伤但没有 PTSD，那么我们可能会在我们的第一次
I don't. I don't. I really feel like if it's something like way off base that I think that there could be harm, I will, but I really just lean in and listen. I feel like correcting people can create a barrier to the relationship. And so, again, my role as the therapist is to listen to what your understanding is and to help you navigate life that way. And so, again, if there's a big area where a redirection needs to happen, we'll get there eventually. But otherwise, I'm just learning what you believe to be true.
几次会谈中在进行饮食失调治疗时谈论它。如果他们有 PTSD，我们将首先进行接地练习。我们将让他们为我们准备好在饮食失调治疗的同时正式进行像认知处理疗法这样的事情。所以我认为这就是伤害产生的地方，永远、永远不想贬低某人的创伤并说，好吧，实际上，不，你没有 PTSD。他们不需要那种纠正。但作为提供者，我们需要知道的是那种创伤经历是如何影响他们的。诊断标准对于勾选框并不重要。它对于
I think for us it comes up a lot in eating disorder treatment with trauma. and everyone will experience trauma in their life and not everyone will go on to develop PTSD. And while I'm really, I'm glad that the word trauma is now in the public lexicon because people go through really traumatic things and forget to label it as such. Like that, that is a big deal that you got through that, that you survive, that you persevere. And when someone comes into treatment and they say they have PTSD, making sure all of our clinicians and myself know to, give them the PTSD inventory, not so that we can say you did or didn't experience trauma, but because the way you approach it is going to be so vastly different. If they experience trauma and don't have PTSD, then we might talk about it in our first
了解我们将如何开始治疗的前几次会谈很重要。还有其他你们遇到的术语吗，人们正在使用，你知道，只是在流行语中，可能来自不同的 DSM？最让我抓狂的是“界限”。我觉得每个人都在谈论界限，有些人使用得正确，而另一些人使用得不正确，这就是我确实感觉到我真的想纠正的欲望的地方。所以我听到，“我不和他们说话是因为界限”，或者“他们做了这个，因为界限，那是错的”，而没有认识到界限是你为自己设定的，而不是强加给别人的。
couple sessions while doing eating disorder treatment. If they have PTSD, we're going to work on grounding exercises first. We're going to get them ready for when we're going to formally do something like cognitive processing therapy alongside the eating disorder treatment. And so I think that's where kind of the harm comes in, would never, ever want to to diminish someone's trauma and say, well, actually, no, you don't have PTSD. They don't need that correction. But what we do need to know as providers is how is that trauma experience affecting them. And the diagnostic criteria is not important for checking a box. It's important
当我想谈论界限到底意味着什么，以及你什么时候是在以一种有助于产生预期效果的方式使用它们时，我遇到了不同程度的阻力。没有人说他们设定界限是因为他们想发生坏事，对吧？他们设定界限是有预期效果的。但当他们没有正确使用它们时，只会带来更多的人际冲突、更多的伤害、更多的困惑。所以界限是我的词。我的触发词。触发可能是另一个词。触发。是的。是的。你有词吗，Caldwell 博士，抱歉。不，不，你先请。这是一个好问题。Caldwell Harvey 博士，你有那样的词吗？是的，我想，我之前提到过，但冒名顶替现象，冒名顶替综合症真的，
for knowing how we're going to begin our first several sessions of treatment. Are there other terms out there that you're running into that people are using and, you know, just sort of popular speech that have come from probably the different. DSM? The one that drives me the most nuts is boundaries. I feel like everyone's talking about boundaries and some people are using them correctly and other people use them incorrectly and that's where I do feel my desire to really want to correct. So I'll hear the, I'm not talking to them because of boundaries or they did this and that was wrong because of boundaries and not recognizing that boundaries are something that you set for yourself versus impose on other people.
我只是，它让我非常心烦。我认为细微差别总是缺失的，它在于假设它是完全内在的，而很多研究告诉我们，它确实应该是你所处的环境中的背景因素，社会政治环境确实影响一个人是否经历这些，是否会有这些类型的感受，但我认为这在公众理解中是缺失的，所以有这种“哦，你只是在说我缺乏自信，这是我的错”，我心想，那不是理论所说的。但我也会想到很多研究是如何隐藏在付费墙和没人读的学术期刊后面的。所以我也会想，好吧，某人怎么知道这已经在不同人群中研究过了？
And I met with various levels of resistance when wanting to talk about what boundaries actually mean and when are you using them in a way that is helping to have the desired effect. No one says that they're having boundaries because they want something bad to happen, right? They have a desired effect for why they're setting boundaries. But when they're not using them correctly, it's just going to bring more relationship strife, more harm, more confusion. So boundaries is my word. my trigger word. Trigger could be another word. Trigger. Yeah. Yeah. Do you have a word, Dr. Caldwell, I'll sorry. No, no, go ahead. That's a good question. Dr. Caldwell, Harvard, do you have a word like that? Yeah, I think, I brought this up before, but imposter phenomenon, imposter syndrome really,
某人怎么知道？所以我只是留下，好吧，我们该拿它怎么办？好吧，我们能做什么？我的意思是，心理学家能做些什么来帮助人们更好地理解这些术语并正确使用它们？是的。我真正相信的一件事是，我们应该创造好的内容，并在此基础上辩论现有的内容。所以我经常看到心理健康专业人士展示人们以我们
I just, it makes me very upset. I think the nuance is always missing and it's in the assumption that it is completely internal when a lot of the research is telling us that it does and it should be contextual factors in the environment that you're in social political environment does influence whether or not somebody experiences these has these types of feelings but I think that that is missing from public understanding and so there's this oh you're just saying I lack confidence and it's my fault and I'm like that is not what the theory says but then I also think about how a lot of the research is hidden behind paywalls and in academic journals that nobody reads. And so that I also am like, well, how does somebody know that this has been studied on diverse populations?
会说错误的方式使用某事，然后创造这种反叙事辩论。我认为这很有趣，但我也认为，它可能会让人感到羞耻。当我想到这种动态时，通常是他们正在辩论的那个人拥有公众的耳朵，对吧？所以我心想，从我们的最终目标（即帮助人们将他们的语言与像有帮助和准确的东西对齐）来看，这在长期内会奏效吗？所以我们占领市场，我认为是我们能用好的内容做的一件事。所以如果他们是网红，如果他们是任何创造内容的人，如果他们查一个词，他们应该发现我们已经用他们能理解的通俗语言写了一些关于它的东西。
How would somebody know that? And so that I'm just left like, well, what do we do with it? Well, what can we do? I mean, what can psychologists do to help people better understand the terms and use them properly? Yeah. One of the things that I really believe in is that we should. should be creating good content and doing that over debating existing content. So I see a lot of the times mental health professionals showing clips of people using something in a way that we would
别人怎么会知道呢？所以我只是感到困惑，我们该怎么处理这些信息？我们能做什么？我的意思是，心理学家能做些什么来帮助人们更好地理解这些术语并正确使用它们？是的。我坚信的一点是，我们应该创造优质的内容，而不是去争论现有的内容。我经常看到心理健康专业人士展示一些人以我们认为错误的方式使用术语的片段，然后制造这种反驳性的辩论。我认为这很有娱乐性，但我也觉得这可能会让人感到羞愧。当我思考这种动态时，通常被辩论的对象是那些拥有公众影响力的人，对吧？所以我一直在想，从我们的最终目标来看，这在长期内是否有效？我们的目标是帮助人们使他们的语言与有益且准确的内容保持一致。因此，我认为我们可以通过创造优质内容来占领市场。这样，无论是网红还是任何内容创作者，如果他们搜索一个词，他们应该能找到我们用通俗易懂的语言所撰写的相关内容。
say is wrong and then creating this counter-narrative debate. I think it's entertaining, but it also, I think, could be shaming. And when I think about the dynamic, it's typically the person that they're debating that has the ear of the public. right? And so I'm thinking, like, is this going to work long term in terms of what our end goal is, which is to help people align their language with something that is like helpful and accurate. And so for us to saturate the market, I think is one thing we can do with good content. So if they're influencers, if they're anybody creating content, if they look up a word, they should find us having written something about it in lay terms that they can understand.
我认为这很有娱乐性，但我也觉得这可能会让人感到羞愧。当我思考这种动态时，通常被辩论的对象是那些拥有公众影响力的人，对吧？所以我一直在想，从我们的最终目标来看，这在长期内是否有效？我们的目标是帮助人们使他们的语言与有益且准确的内容保持一致。因此，我认为我们可以通过创造优质内容来占领市场。这样，无论是网红还是任何内容创作者，如果他们搜索一个词，他们应该能找到我们用通俗易懂的语言所撰写的相关内容。
Everyone's not going to do their research, but for those that, do, it should be easily accessible in there. For us, with a lot of the adolescents we work with, we talk about the word triggers. So there are things that are triggering and makes you want to use your eating disorder behaviors. And it can be understandably exhausting for parents if their teenager is calling every single thing they do triggering. And so that's when we talk with the adolescent and we're like, okay, tell us what you mean by the word. What are you trying to signal? when are you using the word triggering to say, it is really hard for me to resist my urge versus I am definitely going to resist. I will be unable. I will, I will restrict. I will binge. I will engage in one of
并不是每个人都会去做研究，但对于那些愿意做的人来说，这些信息应该很容易获取。对我们来说，在与许多青少年合作时，我们会讨论“触发点”这个词。有些事情会引发你的情绪，让你想要采取进食障碍的行为。如果青少年把他们做的每一件事都称为“触发”，这对父母来说是可以理解的，会让人精疲力竭。所以这时我们会和青少年沟通，我们会说，好吧，告诉我们你这个词的意思。你想表达什么信号？你什么时候用“触发”这个词来表示“我真的很难抵制我的冲动”，而不是“我肯定会抵制”。我做不到。我会，我会限制饮食。我会暴饮暴食。我会参与其中一种
my eating disorder habits. And so talking about when do you mean I'm uncomfortable versus when do you mean this is really making me want to use my eating disorder behavior? And then why? Why should you adjust your language? Because your parents want to help you. And they're not going to be able to do that if we don't add some nuance to it. I actually think of when my son was younger, anytime he felt something other than happiness or joy, he'd say he felt bored. But sometimes bored meant he was sad.
我的进食障碍习惯。所以要讨论你什么时候是指“我不舒服”，什么时候是指“这真的让我想要采取进食障碍行为”？然后为什么？你为什么要调整你的语言？因为你的父母想帮助你。如果我们不增加一些细微差别，他们就无法做到这一点。我实际上想到了我儿子小时候，每当他感到除了快乐或喜悦之外的任何情绪时，他都会说他感到无聊。但有时无聊意味着他很难过。
Sometimes bored meant he was angry, sometimes bored. And so it's really about understanding why they're using the word and how can we help expand their vocabulary so they can use the word they mean when they mean to use it. Are there good resources out there that you would point people to? I'm asking for our listeners, and I get what you said, Dr. Caldwell, Harvey, that a lot of this is behind firewalls because it's in academic literature, which people probably aren't going to read anyway. But, I mean, where's a good place to go to really understand the lexicon? Yeah, good question.
有时无聊意味着他很生气，有时无聊。所以这实际上是关于理解他们为什么使用这个词，以及我们如何帮助扩展他们的词汇量，以便他们能在想用的时候用上准确的词。有没有什么好的资源可以推荐给人们？我是为我们的听众问的，我明白你说的，Caldwell Harvey 博士，很多内容都在防火墙后面，因为它们在学术文献中，人们可能无论如何都不会去读。但是，我的意思是，去哪里可以真正理解这些词汇？是的，好问题。
I mean, I think APA has been doing a really great job with putting out short form articles on different topics. I think this podcast does a good job with that. And there are so many psychologists, influencers that are popping up, creating great content. I'd be happy to share some and that are, yeah, creating short form videos talking about these topics. And so I think following someone with a mental health background in terms of education is really important. And I think it's okay to listen to people who don't, but to understand where you should actually be getting the content that informs your knowledge around something. so serious as your mental health and mental illness. I think, and I echo plus one every suggestion you just had.
我的意思是，我认为美国心理学会（APA）在发布关于不同主题的短篇简报方面做得非常好。我认为这个播客在这方面做得也不错。现在涌现出许多心理学家和网红，他们正在创作很棒的内容。我很乐意分享一些，他们确实在创作谈论这些话题的短视频。所以我认为关注一个在教育方面有心理健康背景的人非常重要。我认为听那些没有背景的人说话也没关系，但要明白你应该从哪里真正获取那些为你提供心理健康和精神疾病相关知识的内容。我认为，我完全赞同你刚才提出的每一条建议。
And I'll add, I really like the influencers that combine the professional experience with the lived experience. I think sometimes when you're watching just one or the other is where things get mixed. And really, maybe we can put in the show notes some of our favorite social media, some favorite influencers we all follow that we think do a good job with this. Yeah, that would be very helpful. Well, this has been fascinating. I want to thank you both for joining me, and I hope we have helped our listeners better understand how to use psychological language more accurately going forward. Thank you for having us. Yes, thank you. This has been a conversation that I feel like could continue on and on.
我还要补充一点，我真的很喜欢那些将专业经验与生活经验相结合的网红。我认为有时当你只看其中一个时，事情就会变得混乱。也许我们可以把我们最喜欢的一些社交媒体账号和我们都关注的、认为做得很好的网红放在节目说明里。是的，那会非常有帮助。好吧，这太令人着迷了。我要感谢你们两位加入我，我希望我们已经帮助我们的听众更好地理解了如何在未来更准确地使用心理学术语。谢谢你们邀请我们。是的，谢谢。我觉得这是一场可以一直持续下去的对话。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. For those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA, you can join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist. The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine, Monitor on Psychology, as well as discounts on our books and other publications. So if psychology is your passion, or if you just want to know more about the science, you can become a supporter by visiting at.a.org. slash speaking. That's at.a.apa.org slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman.
您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢所听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。对于那些想了解更多关于心理学和美国心理学会工作的人，您可以加入我们成为支持者。您不必是心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学监测》，以及我们的书籍和其他出版物的折扣。所以，如果心理学是您的热情所在，或者如果您只是想了解更多关于这门科学的知识，您可以访问 at.a.org/speaking 成为支持者。网址是 at.a.apa.org/speaking。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。
Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。我是 Kim Mills。放松一下，让 Ralph's 的配送服务来处理您本周的杂货采购吧。我们只从最新鲜的商品开始，然后查看您的清单并仔细挑选每一件商品。然后我们打包好，并在短短 30 分钟内送达，这样您就可以确信这就是您订购的商品。新鲜杂货，随心所欲，尽在 Ralph's 配送和自提服务。现在，您的第一笔配送或自提订单可节省 20 美元。Ralph's，为每个人提供新鲜。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。